good to see you guys how are you hello
how are you
i'm doing very well and i was so excited
for season three after like the
cliffhanger of season two and
very delighted
by the way the first episode went like
just incredible stuff this is gonna air
after everyone gets a chance to see it
so i want to talk about that sequence
like there's a lot of fight sequences in
the last two seasons of uh of umbrella
academy what is more difficult doing the
fight sequences in the fight
choreography or doing a big dance number
like that
oh man well for me personally the dance
was a lot harder than the fighting
i've done a fair few fight scenes but
i've never done a dance sequence like
that um
yeah
thank god for my wife right my my wife
laura
used to dance so she we got the
the choreography through our inboxes you
know weeks before and i remember seeing
these dancers doing what we were going
to do fast yeah like i'm like we're
never going to be able to do that
and then my wife was like no no you'll
be fine i'll show you how to do it and
she
sort of taught me before we started
getting into rehearsals a few of the
steps because i think if she hadn't done
that i'd have been a mess when we got to
rehearsals yeah it's hard to get over
that that sort of barrier of belief
not going to be able to get it up to
that tempo
it's not going to be able to happen but
then you know you do it this
you know experience folks around and
they sort of just teach you and guide
you like a child nurture you through
yeah our choreographers were amazing so
that criticism was so patient with us
yeah yeah
john thank you both yeah jonathan boffin
was great
john higginbotham um being a fan of the
show one of the great things is just
being surprised like constantly being
surprised not knowing where twists and
turns are gonna come from if you find
yourselves three seasons in still being
surprised by what goes on in the show
you know i i i watched the show recently
in lieu of doing all of the promotion
and stuff and i was continuously
surprised even by scenes i was in yeah
yeah you know you shoot a lot over six
seven months and so your priority
becomes the present and what's shot is
shot and it's done and it's done and
it's part of the post-production team
and a big shout out to the editors of
umbrella in fairness they make us look
more attractive slick and funny than we
actually are
but um
yeah oh yeah i'm totally surprised
how it leans into the twists and the
gangs it's a very ballsy show and it's
part of the beauty of being part of this
show you know that you you as an actor
you know we we're very blessed in this
show because
there are shows where it does become
very predictable to be a part of and
this just is not that you know you're
always surprised and that's that's great
as a gift as an actor yeah
um something else that i think fans
really adore about the show is the fact
that
you know you're getting to watch these
family members grow and change every
single time we come back to it right
how important was it for you all to get
victor's coming out story correct
oh well yeah you don't want to
misrepresent that yeah
i think if it was done wrong we were all
had something to say about it but i mean
obviously you know elliot was losing
leading that charge but yeah yes it was
very important for steve blackman you
know he was
the first to say you know as the writer
and the creator of the show that they've
got to get it right and he brought in
the right people yeah
consulting with glad glad which is a
um
organization which
essentially
fights so that
gay and trans people are accurately
depicted in films and television i
actually spoke to them a good bit too
they were really interesting yeah like
they're called nick adams
trans men that's right yeah i remember
yeah yeah so yeah they you know went
about it the right way i think you know
yeah
um finally i was talking to steve and he
did say
that you know he's always got ideas for
what's coming next he's like i know
what's going to come next in season four
does he ever tell you
what's what he has in mind for the
future
very little very very literally
in his short term future my cards are
here yeah
really yeah
and he occasionally does that yeah yeah
but then brings him straight back yeah
because he knows actors can be quite
contrarian and argumentative
especially if they're good
well i gotta say congrats again on a
fantastic third season so great talking
with you guys thank you so much